well thanks for coming I you know would
love to answer any questions if you guys
want to do as much QA and then maybe
take a couple selfies hug it out and
then uh and then I'll get mentally
prepared for my talk anybody have any
questions I think it's predicated on the
ambition and the lifecycle of where
you're at right I think the way I think
about businesses is actually the way I
think about parenting I don't expect the
three-year-old to have everything
figured out yet right and so I think it
depends on the makeup of a team you know
you look at a team like this and
everybody's gonna have their strengths
and weaknesses and the one thing I do
see a lot of because I'm a little bit
more of a hustler entrepreneur and
didn't come from it I wasn't a developer
I came up from being selling stuff and
in a wine store and so I get a lot of
hustlers and and entrepreneurs that come
to me that want to be in the tech
business and they come up with these
ideas and then they want a dev shop to
build it for them and they're gonna
launch this huge but we're they're gonna
be the next Facebook because of this
idea and then I go you're in the tech
business and you don't have a tech
co-founder you know so I see that every
day so I think if the ambition is very
large and it's tech centric you need to
have a tech co-founder to really build
an actual big business I think if you're
building a fashion brand and there's
products like Magento and Shopify and
WordPress and already in the marketplace
and your ambition is to build a 10
million dollar skarf business well then
you don't need to be the tech co-founder
there's tools that can get you there
through Shopify and maybe it's more
about the marketing skills or how do you
know how do you market the crayons you
know you don't necessarily need so I
think it I think you have to go
backwards I think the thing that
everybody makes mistakes with I think
one of the best things I've ever done
and I really haven't I articulated about
my love of the journey but I don't talk
enough about the way I strategize I kind
of like playing the role of like
charismatic crazy guy but I
I definitely think about stuff quite a
bit and I think the best way to win is
to know where the hell you're going and
so and the reason I've been pushing
self-awareness is not everybody here is
destined to build a 500 million dollar
thing I also think it's crazy that if
people don't realize how amazing it is
to build a 1 million dollar thing if you
can build a $1,000,000 a year revenue
business and run on 30% in that price
you have a crazy life and so we have
this whole world of everybody trying to
achieve for something that's virtually
impossible and they're putting
themselves in a position where by trying
to build something impossible they're
gonna end up working for a bank because
the one thing that people haven't
factored in yet is globally the economy
has been pretty good for the last decade
or at least eight years and I my biggest
concern is the next economic slowdown
right and obviously Ireland's had
different things going on than UK and
brexit for the UK and the US and
everybody has their own micro economic
things but I think the reality is
globally right now things are good you
know things people are tense about
politics but economic realities end all
the people that made money in the 2000s
or have family money are pouring money
into start-up land a rugby startup can
actually get money from some individual
you know that made money prior I mean
the amount of 25 and $50,000 stupid
cheques I've written in the last five
years you know and so when that goes
away what happens and so I think I think
that um that's a long-winded answer for
a couple things one you need to know
what your ambition is right - you have
to figure out if what you're doing now
is just the place where you're
transitioning into the next chapter your
career or is this the thing that you
want to try to build and so if you
actually decided from a strategical
standpoint then the next 2-3 years is
really just about learning less
posturing faking it to make it more just
learning tasting it understanding the
grass is not always greener
yeah startup land is better than finance
land because people aren't as douchey or
this and that but there's a lot of
things that aren't as good like pressure
like it's all on you like the well then
if you've made the
macro decision that this is a stepping
stone and this is how you're gonna go
about the world all of a sudden you're
not spending most of your time trying to
figure out how to make the most money
out of this you're taking it in a
totally different mindset you've almost
got a university like mentality to the
execution you don't want to go out of
business you don't want to have to go
back to get a job but I would I would
this is advice I'm giving you no I'm
giving advice to everybody right now you
really have to know what you're doing
like at the macro and the other thing is
you have to be flexible enough to know
what changes but your ambition is that
at 19 and 15 and 22 is different than
what your ambition is at 41 and you have
to be flexible in that reality so I
think it's a it's a strategic answer you
know and I think that um I think you
need to think about I think you need to
think about tasting everything because
you're a young man and you want to
figure out what the hell you like and
what you're good at there's just an
incredible you know like kind of access
point of like what you're great at and
what you love when you stumble into
being somebody like me you really win
when what you're naturally great at is
what you naturally love the most and
away you go
the amount of people that I meet every
day that are great at something but have
no interest in being a CFO they love
their insane with numbers but they don't
want to do it they want to sing right or
you know like and so that's tough
you see it in athletics like people
don't understand athletes the amount of
athletes that just do it because it was
the best way for in the same way that
somebody goes and becomes an accountant
and they don't love competition and they
don't love the sport it's crazy you know
when you look at them because you're
like you're one of the 15 but you know
and they don't love it which is why
they're not the greatest athlete of all
time the greatest athletes of all time
are the ones who love it and have it and
so I think what you need to do is taste
everything it's kind of like food you
know what your favorite food is if you
only eat one food so I would take
advantage of your youth and and your
flexibility at this kind of age and try
to taste everything play with everything
figure out what you might be good at
what you might like and then you make a
decision you know when I think about
being 41 years old and feeling as young
as I feel like I'm 10 years old
like I feel like I have my whole life in
front of me and I think that's very
difficult
for youngsters to realize that I where
I'm sure some of us that have lived a
little bit longer you know you just
don't like when I was 20 how old are you
when I was 26 41 seems like a [ __ ]
long way away you know like like my 8 my
8 year old cuz 8 years old her cousin
who worked with me at Wine Library
seemed old to me at you know he was 34
when I was 26 so 41 [ __ ] like like it's
funny for me to think about like how
you're seeing me but I'm telling you
you're gonna feel exactly the way you
feel right now at 41 and so that's
interesting because when people
understand that you can start deploying
more patients because right now you want
to prove it you've got right yeah
quickly you know I can read that because
you're in the fake like first words out
of your mouth always are such an
indicator of what's on your mind you
know I don't I never care to fake it
till I made it because I didn't care
what people thought when you could
eliminate that [ __ ] changes real quick
you know even think about high school
and then going into college like the
high schools so tough for people because
that's the apex of when everything is
about what other people think and then
you love the transition to university or
to last year of high school because you
care a little less right but those first
couple years of high school I don't know
the school system exactly I guess
they're more like like everybody's
wrapped up in that 12 to 17 year old age
of like everything's about what
everybody else thinks so that's why so
many people hate that era I just never
went through that luckily just
hardwiring good parenting serendipity
circumstance wrapping my self-esteem and
things that I was great at not really
I'm not really good at thinking about
what I'm bad at even in interviews the
only time I get stumped is they're like
what do you struggle with or or what
what's a failure I'm like uh I just
don't even like quantify it I don't
think it's worth it
I think people dwell too much
I give away all my best advice I'm a
daily B I'm showing inside meetings to
what the strategy of my company is and
my competitors can just watch it and
copy I mean it's crazy what I'm actually
doing
because it speaks to my confidence that
I'm always gonna keep inventing the next
thing and my understanding that 99% of
people are gonna do anything about it
anyway so I just bought pure Wow
which is a women's media publishing
company it's like a refinery29
competitor I saw they were finding 29
CEO at CES and I rolled up on him and
we've been friends for a long time
acquaintances friendly and yeah he had a
good vibe but like I addressed it
immediately listen you know I want to
rip your head off like that I'm
competitive it's a game like that's what
I do I'm like but but then I said to him
you know but but honestly I think we
should join up and we should go after
Conde nest and and Hearst and there's
much bigger media women companies than
us together we can really do some damage
and I don't care if I get 50 cents or 30
cents on the dollar I think the best
collaborations are the most unlikely
when Burger King asked McDonald's on
that like that campaign they didn't know
if you guys saw this where they asked to
make a love child of the Big Mac and the
whopper to me there's if tomorrow Nike
and Adidas in the height of Easy's going
after the Nike brand did a collaboration
to me you even said it the most unlikely
ones it's easy when a crayon company
does a JV with like a sock company and
they make a Co pact like they're not
really competing I think the most
interesting ones are when you have real
genuine competition and people
collaborate and so I think the ones that
are most interesting is when Facebook
and snapchat will have secret meetings
and say you know what we have to team up
on vertical video because that's bigger
than what we're competing against each
other because we have to take down
television ads that's interest you know
I love that stuff you know I know that's
pretty frothy but I think that's when it
gets most interesting that so we so
FedEx and UPS should get together and
say listen Amazon and uber are dangerous
what can we do together
disruptor disruptors and its most
interesting to me when the incumbents
that are on the verge of being disrupted
are smart enough to disrupt so like for
example every hotel company in the world
should have gotten together threw money
together and then bought residential and
then created in the Airbnb competitor
you know what I mean
that to me is really neat now I know
that's pretty heavy on a more small
business level I think it gets really
interesting when the next generation
comes in and they yell at their father
that not everything is competition and
you can do business with the guy down
the street my best collaborations was
when I had no money
when Wine Library had no money none we
were doing three million three point
eight million dollars a year ten percent
gross profit before expense we had no
money there's no marketing budget my
first years marketing budget was
fourteen thousand dollars what did I do
I went to a lot of the other local
businesses in Millburn and asked them if
I could put a bottle of wine on their
counter at the barber shop with little
coupons yes yes yes human inefficiencies
fear ego I don't need you I can do it
cynicism I don't trust you
you're not gonna leave when I leave
you're gonna just take the Flyers
throw them in the garbage and drink my
wine that's what holding up my dad back
cynicism you know yeah cynicism
yes experience you know I think I think
young kids are getting tricked right now
and think just because it's a technology
boom and just because they understand it
that they have this great advantage over
a 45 year old executors it's audacity
which I love channeled properly it gives
them the lack of fear to do things so I
really don't talk a lot about it because
I don't want to stop it because I think
it's the greatest gift as well but I
think it's patience I think it's lack of
experience and the biggest one is lack
of talent
every young kid thinks they're entitled
to be an entrepreneur now it's the cool
thing truth is it's not gonna work out
like it just isn't the math doesn't work
out like nineteen eight percent of the
people that are starting startups are
gonna lose and again the reason I
started with the economic like the
economic growth of the globe is keeping
a fake entrepreneur alive most of your
friends that in their 20s that have
businesses aren't actually making money
if they're in tech they've raised
capital and they're losing money every
month that's ultimately something that
doesn't work out no you're being you're
being subjected to age discrimination so
the way to combat it is to not dwell on
it and not try to sell people who aren't
sellable it's a volume game just go to
every business instead of focusing on
trying to convince the dog shop owner
that he's making a mistake
though one of the great things I've
always done cuz I started off as a young
kid and nobody I mean I I started off as
like they would walk into my family
business and I'm like can I help you
with wine and they're like you can't
help me with wine for the first seven
years they were right I was 15 years old
they were but I knew a lot more and if
they gave me data I could tell them what
they should drink but I think that um
one thing I learned very early on by all
that rejection both being a bad student
and both being a kid that trying to sell
wine when he was underage and nobody
would listen to him is that is that you
can't sell people that aren't sellable
you're way better off putting your
energy and crushing it for the people
that give you an at-bat right versus the
people that aren't
company and then - I'm preschools it's a
niche market I have a master's in
preschool education I have a degree but
I still feel I talked to over thousand
preschool providers don't service with
them I'm talking to them every day but
I'm still not sure how to market the
products to them just cuz it's small and
yeah so what your advice on marketing to
me as far as investing you've kind of
heard my themes I've not been investing
much at all I'm about to do this new
Apple show where I'm one of the you know
mentors and I think it's gonna put me in
the light of investing a lot again so
I'm gonna I have to figure out what my
strategy is because I'm gonna have a
great amount of deal flow but I do think
we're in an oversaturated overvalued
market so I've been doing almost no
investing if I was to invest now it's
only betting on the jockey and they've
had to be successful before like now
listen Mark Zuckerberg was not
successful before Evan Spiegel was not
successful before I'm gonna leave money
on the table in an incredible way by
having that strategy I just need to go
through this cycle
I don't like it right now and so I'd
rather invest in somebody who's done it
before and is on their second or third
because it gives me data that they've
been able to navigate actually building
a business versus building a machine
that's build for fundraising because
that's the majority of what's being
built right now no you should go talk to
them one-on-one the best thing to do
ever is to go one-on-one and reverse
engineer what made you get the first 10
people to buy it and then make that your
strategy I'm a very big fan of that like
instead of guessing what it's gonna be
go and sell it see what the common theme
was that made people buy it and then
scale that in your communications
digital is not a it's not a tactic
digital is where people's attention is
so what you put into the digital is what
matters just having a Facebook strategy
right it's what you say like the
creative is still the variable of
success it's what you say
really depending on our community and
our followers to reach me attract funds
volunteers will join us on the projects
abroad in Kenya it was quite a let's say
take spots to get to let say around
1,000 followers different I mean what
what kind of tips Australian do you have
to get to the next um so first of all
you shouldn't worry about things like
that like like in general just even
worrying about those proxies like to me
I assume you're talking about 1,000
followers across Facebook Twitter like
things like that is that we mean so
first of all I think the bigger question
is what does that mean so for example my
you know what I mean of course its depth
versus width so if you're only KPI was
10,000 followers we could create a
word-of-mouth distribution strategy that
could write like click this it auto
populates all this it you gain a 5 why
people follow you I mean you can give
away an ID watch and like and pick up
500 followers right so I I think that
you need to you need to think about it
differently so for example if the Hedeby
the united nations was one of your
followers and wanted to always talk
about what you're doing that's far more
interesting to me than having 48
thousand random people following you on
Instagram I think that's the real answer
the way to get to the best version of
that real answer is content and so what
I would do if I were you guys is I would
shift into the mindset of thinking that
you're a media company , and geo and
what that would do and I actually think
that's the advice I would give all of
you so I think you should blog every day
about the world of preschool and are
like everything profile a teacher
speak about something that happened 50
years ago a media company if you all
think of yourself as a media company
media content is the gateway to the
business look what I do I gary am a
media company it's the Gateway to
building the fastest biggest growing
agency in the history of advertising
I always say to people if they really
pay attention to what I'm doing they'll
get much more value out of me than
anything else like why am i making so
much video why am i documenting
everything why am i you know producing a
t-shirt why am i doing the Apple show
why why am i doing what I'm doing no
matter I'll never be as great as a
communicator as I am right and I'm
really good at it and so I've been
successful I'll never be able to fully
synthesize ahead of my own actions so
what does that mean that means you
should write a medium blog post every
week it means that you should do a
podcast in the NGO space every week why
did Scott Harrison and Adam Braun from
pop and pencils of promise
excuse-me peso promise and charity water
become such players because they were
they were club promoters they were
marketers they were they treated it
differently and and the truth is too
many people in the NGO spoke NGO space
take for granted people's goodwill they
think just cuz they're an NGO people
should give a [ __ ] there's a trillion
NGOs there's a trillion things that are
trying to do good for the world so
content podcast video written quotes
pictures and then tactics 15 hashtags
when you post your picture on Instagram
three times a day
like corporate social responsibility of
course I'm curious you're seen if you
ever come across these kind of subjects
and what's interesting for them so what
we could offer the first thing you have
to do is realize they're full of [ __ ]
they just are like yeah it's it's
companies do for purpose ninety-nine
point seven percent of time for Commerce
interests they think it looks good to
the person they're trying to sell soap
to and so the second you take the
romance out of it and say okay great
the this company is very excited about
us they're not excited about you they're
excited about using you as a proxy to
make themselves look like the reason I
never talk about my nonprofit work which
is substantial financially in time
committed is because I am disgusted by
my fancy friends that use it to paint a
picture that they're a good human being
I love that people some people think
that I'm too self promotional I'm
comfortable promoting about my vanity
I'm not comfortable in promoting my
heart I think that you just do that so
it's the reverse you know I love when
people razz me and fall for tricks of
what other people are doing it's just
very basic thinking I think when you
take the romance out you've got a much
better chance of being successful with
those companies if you walk in there and
realize okay this is business and what
they really care about is their brand
being associated with something that's
good
which then leads to more selling stuff
your strategies start changing on what
you say you're willing to do with them
you start getting more of them to do
things that you want to do you always
have to know what the real game is yes
it's hard it's hard really hard
you're gonna be so you're gonna be
slower you're gonna be slower
communicate to who the world you're
almost getting very person with the
people who are kind of the key holders
or the gatekeepers okay well what do you
what what do you what do you need from
them I need to get me into an
accelerator to get into that structure
nearly to think I think I I think you
have to go to the decision maker in that
accelerator tell the truth of your world
and realize that 99% of decision makers
in that situation aren't gonna give a
[ __ ] about your hip retic he was he was
like oh you remember six months ago you
applied you're a single mom aren't you
you're any kin you wouldn't have noticed
that yeah my god he's great inside he's
just one of the 99 you just got a [ __ ]
you know you just gotta find the one and
and by and by the way and by the way I
do want to say something cuz people
don't think about this cuz I just went
through this with this new Apple show
he's got a fiscal responsibility these
accelerators were given money by people
like like you know like it's you know
the wrong the raw game of business is
very unforgiving I don't think these VCS
i Raz them all the time because I want
to remind entrepreneurs that their model
is the following they're gonna give you
all bad advice except for the one that
gets through and pays for everything
they're gonna push all your companies
too hard
and not patients because their motto is
predicated on getting one to break
through and pay for the whole fund so
they push everybody to be a huge exit
most fail one gets through they win but
the truth is somebody keep them money
when I write a check is an LP a limited
partner and I write a 500,000 our track
I'm trusting that individual to return
my money and with profit my could put it
in the stock market I could buy real
estate I can this is my family I earned
of my money so so they have a
responsibility so now I think there's
grace and I think there's ways to be a
polite human being and I think yeah but
the worlds of honestly the world's a
funny place right like I think the
reason I over index is I've found some
sort of balance on me I'm massively
aggressive and a good dude and people
are able to like get real you know I'm
I'm giving you an answer that most
people aren't giving which is I'm not so
sold they're wrong but I do believe that
somebody will be like hey listen I'm not
worried that this may take thirteen
years or four or seven or nine problem
is they're impatient
everybody's impatient there's not just a
young kid thing the world is impatient
so I think what again I think it's a
similar answer I've given a couple times
now let me give you a great macro piece
advice eliminate emotion be empathetic
you know what your headache is like hey
[ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm a single mom and
I'm doing it right and I've got things
to do
but be empathetic to him I look at him
and say he might really need this exit
like maybe he you know maybe who the
hell knows what happened in his life
maybe he needs this investment period of
his life everybody just assumes that
because they're an accelerator the most
of the people that I know that run
accelerators have no money like this is
the thing that needs to make them money
they worked 15 years to build a
reputation to be able to get people that
had money to give them money and this is
the moment this is it so you know when
you go to that it's why I never get mad
about anything right you see the rock
reacting doesn't like like it's why I
don't get mad if somebody says you
you're
con artists I'm like okay you've watched
four seconds of one video where I was
peacocking and being like egotistical
cocky self and that's what you think and
i get it fine like i don't expect you to
you know people come up to me in events
like this like i'm sorry i don't know
who you are all these people I'm like
you don't need to be sorry 99% of the
world doesn't know what like like to me
I think empathy is lacking in our world
I think the political climate in all of
our countries and and Europe in the u.s.
is lacking empathy we're going this way
instead of this way and there's no
neither side is right about that so we
lack empathy empathy has been my calling
card the thrift shop is so awesome I'm I
really think that's selling like buying
something and selling it the reason I'm
more excited about it then people
realize is I think I'm teaching a lot of
people a true survival skill like when
you act like the amount of people that
are actually gonna have a successful
startup because on the side they were
going to bookstores buying and selling
and when [ __ ] hits the fan they'll have
a little money to stay alive just long
enough to get out to the other side and
win theirs I'm so proud this may be it's
such a funny thing it seems so weird
like a lot of my tech friends are like
what are you doing but I I'm really
excited about it because I think a lot
of you are gonna learn how to sell you
are it's cool it's cool right it's it's
just like and the other thing is like a
lot of people need money like having
extra money really impacts 97% of people
and so no matter where you are on the
economic scale selling random stuff in
your house that you're not using and
having an extra thousand euros at the
end of the year is better than not and
you learn something it's a real win-win
it's a real win-win it's been really fun
it's been really fun to watch
[Music]